dans le barrio quand le ciel devient
noir les choses tournent mal quand on
était enfant pour nous raconter la
légende
à chaque fois que la tension monte dans
le quartier on entendait le bruit 200
moteurs approcher les gangsters se sont
tournés vers dieu tellement ils
craignaient ce diable c'était qui elle
chicanons
le cartel a tué plusieurs officiers de
police il a l'intention de faire flotter
son drapeau sur la californie j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est un champ de bataille
il savait que ça allait arriver que quoi
allait arriver
la révolution bingo
reste avec moi à telle date avec moi
pour être honnête avec toi je suis perdu
je sais plus quoi faire
j'ai toujours essayé de faire le bien
aujourd'hui je de rendre la justice
c'est ça que je veux devenir c'est le
seul moyen de protéger ma ville
c'est dur dans tes yeux
qu'est ce que tu vois
la rage
connaître son ennemi
c'est moi le roi de cette ville
guerre est déclarée 24 heures avant
qu'ils lui en cela son avenir j'ai ma
famille
moi je ne suis ni bons ni juste moi je
triompherait par le sang
chikane celui qui sème la mort dans
quartier